(upbeat music)
- Well,
welcome back to another episode
of the Addy Hour podcast.
I was just telling today's two guests,
this is actually episode 41,
which is hard for me to believe.
So we're continuing to move forward,
continuing to go strong, and again,
it's always been great just
to seek the feedback from you
all as listeners,
people who have chased me
down on campus to tell me how
important these conversations have been.
People who've reached out to me by email,
people I've just seen in the
community who've told me how
much these conversations really
impact them and help them
think through aspects that you
might be walking through in
your own life, but they
also different perspectives.
So today we have a really
special conversation.
As you all know,
I'm a neuroscientist and we're
gonna be really leaning into
the neuroscience piece today,
but also thinking about
neuroscience and mental health
research and what that
has to do with society,
and whether we feel like that's
impact or flop or a little
bit of both.
So I'll throw that out there
as a provocative question for
you all, but I have two great
guests who are gonna join this
conversation today, Dr. Diana Martinez
and Dr. Steve Muller.
I'll give them both a little
bit of an introduction and that
you hear from them as well.
To start with Dr. Diana Martinez,
she is a professor of psychiatry
at the Columbia University
Irving Medical Center, she's
actually originally from Texas,
went to college in Santa Fe, New Mexico,
where she studied philosophy.
She then moved to New York
State to attend medical school
with a plan to return to Texas,
but instead she became a
psychiatrist who researches
the neuroscience of addiction and has also
become a New Yorker in her own words.
So maybe we'll hear
more about that as well.
So in addition to her research
career, she has two sons,
and as they grew up and became teenagers,
she recognized and realized
that the science could be used
to have a conversation about
drugs, health and safety.
So she now gives seminars to
parents and educators and high
school students where she talks
about the risks of drugs and
how science-based education
can be used to improve safety.
So Diana,
thank you so much for being
here on the podcast and thank
you for all the work you do as well.
- Oh, thank you.
Glad to be here.
And you know, I do love
neuroscience and New York City,
so it's good.
- That's a good combination,
good combination.
Our second guest is Dr. Steve Muller,
who is an associate professor
of neurobiology and behavior
at UC, Irvine.
He has a PhD in bio psychology
from the University of
Michigan and has been researching
how addiction and other
psychiatric disorders
work in the brains of
both humans and rodents.
And he's been doing
this for over 20 years.
Today he's a behavioral
neuroscientist trying to understand
how processes in the brain go
awry in psychiatric disorders.
He uses rats as a preclinical model.
He's someone who loves to
talk about neuroscience.
I'll also ask,
I'll also add that he's a gifted
science communicator and he
also is good about really
learning from established
scientists from the trainees
he teaches and from the
mentors, so a really holistic
approach in that sense,
not just assuming that he knows
all the information, is the,
the quote unquote expert in the room,
but really kind of having
collaborative conversations in the
work that he does.
It also does a lot impact in
terms of having other people
communicate their science to the public,
which is one of the reasons I
was really excited to have him
here on the podcast.
So wanna welcome Dr. Steve Muller as well.
- Thank you so much, Nii.
It's an honor to be here.
- We'll definitely appreciate
both of you being here.
Looking forward to jumping
into this conversation.
And just by way of context for all of you,
the three of us were actually
together at a conference last
August Gordon research
conference on the neurobiology of
addiction.
And at that conference,
Steve was reminding me that
we actually heard a very
intriguing talk from Diana
about philosophy and how that
actually impacts how we
think about addiction and
neuroscience and mental health.
Steve and I actually had a
really extended conversation
after that really thought
provoking a lot of ways.
So we may loop that into this
conversation today as well.
But you all are really in for
a treat in terms of hearing
from both of these individuals
and all the wonderful work
that they're doing to really
help us think about things in a
different way, and again,
we'll get back to that question
about where are we at as a
society in a field?
Like do we actually use and
understand science as we should,
or are there ways that we can improve?
So as I'm talking on screen,
I'm seeing some head reactions
from both our guests.
So I know that there'll be
a lot to talk about there.
But as my listeners know,
I always like to just start
checking in with our guests just
to see how you're doing
day to day in the state
that we're in.
You know, this point May
of 2023 with everything
we've experienced the last few years,
everything that we're
continuing to navigate,
the new things that
we're navigating as well.
So Diana if we could just
start with you and just hear,
you know, how are you doing
today and what occupies you on a
day-to-day basis?
- Ah, good.
Good question.
I'm, what can I say is
finally spring in New York,
it's finally warm and one,
my older son is away at a semester abroad,
he's coming home soon,
so I'm pretty excited.
Haven't seen him in a while,
the longest I've gone without seeing him.
And you know, it's a great time.
It's grant season as usual.
You know,
we all follow the cycles and
certainly when it comes to the
news and current events, you know,
I try and and look for the
positives and hope for the best.
There's it's always a
a rollercoaster ride when
we think of current events.
So, but other than that, you
know, things are going great.
- That's great to hear.
It sounds like a refreshing
time in a lot of ways.
You know, the spring,
things you're anticipating.
I don't know if you're
anticipating with excitement for
grant season in the same way
you're anticipating having your
son come home, but maybe not.
But.
- I actually like writing grants.
Like I like the science of it.
Administrative part is miserable,
but we have a fantastic
administrator who takes care of
that, so it's actually kind of fun.
- That's great to hear.
That's really great to hear
something I've definitely shared
with people as well in terms
of the excitement for the
ideas,
- Right?
- And so that's obviously
you're in the right place if
that's your mode of operation.
Just as an aside to
trainees who are listening,
that's always something to pay
attention to as well because
if that's something that's
completely onerous for you all
the way around,
may wanna think about just
different aspects that you wanna
get into or if there are
aspects of it that you like and
some that you don't also think
creatively about what would
actually fit in terms of career
options and things you might
be looking into.
So just a little bit of an
aside tidbit as we have that
conversation.
Steve, why don't we jump to
you and see how you're doing
these days?
- I'm doing pretty well the,
a lot of changes in my life
over the course of last few
years as probably everyone could
almost say the same type of
thing, when in my case I got married,
I had my first baby about
- Congratulations.
- So thank you. So.
- You look very alert by
the way, for having a baby.
- Well, everything is relative I guess.
But yeah, it's been really fantastic.
You know,
really some ways challenging
in some ways it's a huge change
in my perspective on life
and and on development.
Even looking at kind of how
my little daughter is learning
how to do different things and
how they kind of come online.
And it's just really exciting
to see these kinds of things
in person,
especially given that we
are doing some developmental
research in my lab as well,
trying to understand some
risk factors for addiction and
other kinds of psychiatric
disorders and trying to not do
the wrong thing as always on my mind.
So it's been fun, but I, yeah,
I wouldn't trade it for anything.
- That's great to hear, well
thanks for giving us that,
that full context too,
just in terms of life events
and also how it's changing your
perspective as you move
forward as well, I mean,
in some ways that's a similar
theme between the two of
you, granted maybe different life stages,
but as Diana got into some
of her work in the schools as
her sons were getting older.
And then Steve,
as you're thinking about
the work you're doing in the
context of watching your daughter
grow and develop at these
really early stages of life as well.
So it's refreshing to hear as well.
So on that note, maybe
Steve will loop back to you.
I just wanted to give our
listeners also a sense
of how you got,
how you both got into your
professions and if I can even go
a step further to say your
calling up to this point.
So anything you wanna share
with our listeners about that?
- Sure, yeah.
Like most, I think most
scientific careers,
mine was not something that
I had in mind early on.
It was definitely one of those
things that just kind of life
comes at you kind of thing,
so as an undergraduate, I was,
I took my first class in psychology,
I think as a sophomore at
Loyola University in Chicago,
and I had a great professor.
So this is one of the themes
I think comes up in careers a
lot of times is you just have
an inspiring person that can
kind of make you think about, you know,
the world in a different way in some ways.
And so I got really interested
in psychology and I started
doing social psychology research
in my undergraduate time
and I knew I was really
interested in psychology,
but giving, you know,
undergraduate psychology students
surveys was underwhelming.
Like I felt like there's
a lot of you know,
all the really interesting
questions had been basically
asked already and you know,
kind of diving into these more
smaller and smaller details.
And in some ways I,
I realized I loved the scientific process,
but that wasn't the way
I wanted to go about it.
And so, unfortunately I didn't
know what I wanted to do,
so I applied to a bunch of
graduate schools thinking,
well that's what people do in psychology.
And I think I applied to nine
PhD programs and I got into
none of them and mostly
because I didn't know
what I was doing.
And so I was fortunate that I was,
my application was transferred
to a terminal master's
program at the
University of Chicago.
- Okay.
- Where I was fortunate
to meet another person
that was truly pivotal in my career.
This is Dr. Harriet Dewitt,
who's a human
psycho-pharmacology researcher.
She kind of wanted to know how
drugs work in the brain and
how they change behavior
and that kind of thing.
And she really put me onto
the idea of neuroscience of
addiction.
And so after doing some studies
with her on alcohol and,
and nicotine especially,
and craving and things like
that and how that relates to
relapse and such,
I was fortunate to get into
the University of Michigan the
second time I applied to
PhD programs and worked with
Kent Burridge,
who is a theorist of kind of
what does dopamine do in reward
And behavior and so on.
And so I did my,
I didn't actually work on
dopamine too much there,
but I did look at the, some of the,
the brain substrates now in rats.
- Okay
- Of addiction related
behaviors or motivated behaviors then
into a postdoc.
I started to look more
specifically at addiction training
rats to take drugs and trying
to understand what that does
in the brain.
And especially I've become
more and more interested in
individual differences,
why some individuals get
addicted when they try drugs and
others don't.
And that's kind of what's
been driving me since then in,
since I've started my own
lab about eight years ago
in Irvine, California.
I've really been trying to dive
into those issues and what's
the difference between, you
know, someone who gets addicted,
someone who doesn't, someone
who has other kinds of,
you know, problems in terms
of psychiatric disorders,
depression, and so on as well.
So that's kind of in a
nutshell where how I got here.
- Yeah.
That's great.
We'll definitely appreciate the
work that you do in terms of
understanding addiction,
but then also some of the
coexistence with other psychiatric
illnesses.
But then also just appreciate
the context that you gave as
well, I mean,
I've said this several times
in several other contexts,
but I think it's always helpful
to hear people's stories.
I mean,
there are aspects of your
story that I'm hearing for the
first time.
And also to learn about your
resilience and pivoting in the
middle of that too, you know,
applying to nine graduate
schools and not getting into any
of them at the beginning.
So I think sometimes there's
a tendency for all of us,
but especially students or
trainees coming up to think that
all the professors just kind
of had a straight path and that
things just kind of all
fell in order and then,
then you knew this is what
you were gonna do and then you
stepped into this position
without knowing the journey along
the way.
So I imagine that people hearing
about that aspect of your
journey and how you were able
to actually get a better sense
of what you wanted will actually
help people who might be in
the middle of feeling
confused or not knowing which
direction to go or getting
rejected from a school and not
knowing if they should continue.
So I really appreciate that as well.
- Yeah, I just note that
sometimes, you know,
if I think if I had gotten into
grad school that first time,
I don't think I would be
here sometimes, you know,
life just happens the
way it does, you know,
you could say for a reason or you know,
it's been calling or
whatever you wanna call it.
You know, sometimes your
best laid plans are,
are not the way things go and
maybe that's for the best in
the long run.
- Yeah, really well said.
Really well said.
Deanna, how about you, your path,
as we've heard a little
bit about from your bio,
but it sounds like it wasn't
the path you predicted.
- Definitely not, so
I went to high school,
I grew up in rural Texas and
the town that I went to high
school in,
like no one really went to
college and most people didn't
finish high school.
And so I actually never did
graduate from high school.
I thought I knew better,
I had a job in 12th grade,
I was like, you know,
why go to school would,
I can have like a car and you know,
a job that pays minimum wage
seemed great at the time
and didn't really see the
need to move forward, but oh,
the year during which I should
have been finishing high
school, I did decide to
go to college after all.
And because I didn't have
a high school diploma,
I wasn't really eligible
for most colleges.
- Okay.
- So I ended up
at St. John's College
in Santa Fe, New Mexico
because they didn't require
a high school diploma or
an SAT score.
And I got there not really even
knowing what philosophy was.
Everyone at St. John's gets
a degree in philosophy.
I honestly thought I'd be
reading a lot of Kurt Vonnegut
novels and instead I discovered
the philosophy was really
quite difficult, but it
was a fantastic school,
it was amazing, you know,
we read philosophy, we read,
you know, scientific papers,
we read Newton's Principia
we read all the quantum physics papers.
They were incredible.
And at the time I thought, oh,
maybe I wanna be a physicist
not really knowing what all
that entailed.
And there was a professor at St. John's
who used to take some
students up to Los Alamos
National Laboratories
and at the laboratories,
I met some physicists and they were okay,
they weren't that friendly.
But I met two physicians
who were working on viral
disorders, viral diseases,
and I thought they were the,
the greatest, so that's actually
where I decided to go to,
to medical school
instead of anything else.
And actually, similarly,
I applied to all the
medical schools in Texas
and got into none.
- Hmm.
- But I got into medical
school in New York City at,
at Cornell, and I remember
the day I interviewed,
I wore a borrowed dress
and some high heels.
And it was early January,
it was probably one of
the worst days of my life.
I'd only lived in Texas, Mexico,
and New Mexico before then.
And I had never faced anything
like the gray sludgy slushy
snow.
And the interviews,
each one was worse than the one before it.
I thought for sure I wasn't in.
And I met with the associate
dean who was in charge of
admissions, who was an incredibly kind,
thoughtful person who I do
think gave me the chance at,
at this.
And I told him that I was
never gonna come to this school
and don't even bother to accept me.
- Wow.
- And his response was really,
you're gonna throw everything
away because of one bad day.
Sure enough, I ended up at,
at medical school and
even in medical school,
my plan was to return to Texas
and be a primary care doctor
for rural Texas.
By the end of the four
years I was like, no,
I'm gonna do psychiatry instead.
And then I ended up in
neuroscience research and it was
definitely, you know, some
accidents along the way,
a lot of, you know, as
Steve had mentioned, some,
you know, some, you know,
powerful mentors along the way.
And that's how I ended up here.
- Wow, that's great to hear.
I mean, definitely appreciate
that context as well.
And so many parallels in your stories too,
which I did not anticipate, just in terms,
definitely in terms of
not what you had planned,
but even in terms of, you know,
not getting into schools you'd
apply to the strong role as
you mentioned of mentors
really kind of shaping and
redirecting you and just
having, again, some of that,
that resilience too,
so I think that speaks,
that speaks volumes, as a follow up,
I'm curious how you think your
path actually impacts you on
a day-to-day basis.
Just like the,
the navigation that you had
to take to get to the current
stage and some of the
serendipity, if you wanna call it.
Like how does that actually
impact what you do in your
perspective, and Diana,
we can start with you.
- You know, I definitely
view it as, you know,
I think a lot of life is hard work,
but a lot of it is luck and
just things sort of lining up.
And I'm always incredibly
grateful for that.
And you know, the joke in
my family is that, you know,
if there had been one missed opportunity,
I'd probably be working at the
Walmart in Falfurrias Texas,
although my mom says I'd be the manager.
So, and that.
- Seems appropriate for mom
to say and probably true.
- You know, it's just,
and so I try to be mindful
of that like, and we,
we all tend to,
things we've earned feel very earned.
But really like so much is just
chance and I'm grateful for
those chances and recognize
that that doesn't happen all the
time to other people and to, you know,
with small circumstances for
us had incredibly powerfully
positive outcomes.
But sometimes it goes through
the way and that's why I see a
lot in my research studies people have
substance use disorders.
- Yeah, that's really helpful perspective.
Steve, what about you?
- Well,
I certainly resonate with the
idea of both hard work and
luck being extremely important
in this kind of career.
This is something I
always try to convey to,
to trainees is that there's
some things you can control and
some things you can't and you
kind of wanna try to learn
what is the difference between
those things and then put
yourself in positions
where you can make choices.
This is, to me, the best
career advice that I,
I know how to give, I think is,
is putting yourself in a place
where you have not just one
option that you must do.
Because that's the only thing on a table.
If you can get yourself in
a place where you can choose
between A and B, that's
almost always gonna be better.
And also being open to things
that you didn't expect to be
the choice you're about to make.
You know, those are,
those are, that's certainly
how my career came about.
I've seen many other
scientists that have that,
that aspect to their careers as well.
They just, you know,
being open-minded and,
and taking opportunities when they,
when they come or when you
put yourself in front of 'em.
And then I guess in terms
of how my, you know,
history affects my current
perspective on science,
I certainly consider myself a
psychologist even though I do
studies in rats and a lot
of it is very, you know,
molecular neuroscience,
genetics and so on.
I'm very much coming from a
psychological perspective and
that's really how I try to approach the,
the rat brain trying to
understand what are psychological
processes that might exist in
both humans and rats and how
can we, you know, if we can
understand them then in rats,
maybe we can get some
insights into humans.
But also not expecting
that that's always going
to be the case.
- Mm.
- I think it's really
important to recognize
they're not just little furry humans.
And even when they, for example,
take drugs voluntarily in my lab,
which is what humans
are doing in addiction,
there are some key differences
in most of the studies that
people do.
For example,
the rats don't have much
else going on in their lives,
so why wouldn't they take drugs?
Maybe it's sort of not a
disorder for them in some ways.
So these are the kinds of questions I,
I really think about a lot in
my own lab and ways to try to
improve our rat models and
that certainly comes from my,
my training history and
the experiences I've had
along the way.
- Yeah.
Really great perspective and
appreciate the words of wisdom
that you all are sharing for
people coming up as well.
'Cause I think again, it's a
theme that comes up repeatedly.
I mean I definitely hear that
from more senior scientists.
So even thinking about
some of the folks at Yale,
Dr. George Heninger is one
that comes to mind who really
facilitated and started a lot of molecular
psychiatry work there.
But hearing his story and how
there were so many things that
he didn't anticipate and
basically him just saying,
saying like both of you,
that he was just ready for
the opportunities that came,
even though things that he
really wanted to do fell apart,
things that he never planned
to do opened up and just being
ready to kind of jump
into those opportunities.
So I appreciate the way you both mentioned
that context as well.
And again,
it seems like it's impacting
your work in so many ways,
even as you think about
how you frame things as a
psychologist who's doing
neuroscience or as a physician.
And so I think that's really,
really healthy as well to pick up, Steve,
where you left off in terms
of some of the addiction work
and things like that, it's gonna
be a pretty hard pivot but,
or a quick pivot.
But I'd be curious if you both
also could talk a little bit
about what you think the role
of science is for society.
And Steve,
you already hinted at that in
terms of some things translate
to humans, some things don't, like what,
what do you see is that role?
And to layer it a little bit,
and you can come back to this if you want,
also just thinking about all
the mixed feelings that people
have in society in terms of
pro-science, anti-science,
rodents in science,
and is that helpful or are we
doing things that we shouldn't
be doing?
So I know that's a whole nother
layer so you don't have to
go too much into that, we can
come back to that as well,
but I wanted to at least put it in that
broader context as well.
- Yeah.
So I guess there's sort
of two things that,
that are behind my drive to,
to ask the kinds of
questions that I try to ask
in my own life.
One of them has to do with
ultimately helping people in
society by helping to perhaps
treat some of these or,
or come up with new treatment strategies,
at least for some of these
psychiatric disorders,
which are devastating for so many lives,
including in my own family.
I will say that this is a
huge part of why I'm studying
addiction is when I was in
high school and thinking about
what I'm gonna do with my life.
My uncle, he overdosed of a,
on heroin at the time and
so he was a close uncle and,
you know,
kind of always took a special
shine to myself and my brother
and that just really kind of, you know,
just gave like a sort of fire under,
under me in some ways to,
to just try to figure out why
would someone just throw away
their life like that, you know,
for something that just
doesn't make any sense,
and seeing also him
towards the end, you know,
my grandparents who he
had lived with, they,
they had dementia and so they
were kind of declining pretty
quickly and they had a live-in
kind of caretaker and they
were, you know, he was
coming by all the time and,
and just causing all these
problems and he was just being a
jerk, you know, he was just,
he was stealing all the time.
He was threatening the,
the caretaker and it was getting
to be a dangerous situation
and it just was just so,
it really opened my eyes to
see someone who, you know,
I loved and I was close to.
- Yeah.
- Just turn into a different person.
So obviously this is something
that I think that we need to
do better in neuroscience is
trying to come up with a better
understanding of how the brain
works normally and how it
works in the context of addiction.
How do some of these processes
actually work in the hopes
that we then can leverage that
information to actually come
up with new treatment strategies.
And then the other thing
that really drives me is,
is this idea of it actually, Dr. Martinez,
you mentioned that you were
originally interested in physics
and that's something that also
another commonality we have.
I didn't find myself
especially good at physics,
I don't think,
but the idea of kind of
understanding where the,
what's going on with the
universe, like how did the,
where do we come from in that way?
It just struck me as one of the
biggest questions and one of
the biggest mysteries out there,
and so I kind of had in mind
that that was something that I
would perhaps like to pursue
in an intellectual way.
But then I came upon
neuroscience and I realized that
there's like almost as big of
a mystery right here inside of
our heads.
And so that just really, you know,
the rest is sort of history trying to,
trying to pursue these really
huge questions that are deeply
meaningful for what it is to
be human and what it is to be,
you know, a person in society that's,
so that's I guess the
two pillars of kind of
my take on your question there.
- Yeah, no, that's really,
really helpful perspective
as well and I appreciate,
you know,
you kind of sharing where that
initial passion and then fire
came from in a lot of ways as well.
Diana, anything you wanna react to
and what Steven said or even to
answer the question for yourself as well.
- Sure, so if we go
to, you know, how does,
how does science fit in with society?
I think it's a very compelling question.
A number of years ago
as I as you mentioned my bio,
I started giving talks to high
school students and you know,
my older son is now 20,
when he was about 15 when
he was in high school,
there was a party where everyone
was drinking at the party
and a girl fell out of a window
in a New York City apartment
building and didn't survive.
- Wow.
- And when I heard this
story I was just like,
these are the things that
happened when I was in high school
and it's still, you know,
another generation and we're
still having these issues
happen from teenage drug
use, so I started to take,
I decided to take the science
and go start talking to
parents, educators and
teenagers and you know,
it was hard 'cause the
first thing I wanna do when,
when you're a parent and you
have your kids is you'll,
and they're teenagers, you
wanna be like, don't use drugs,
you'll die, don't use drugs.
Terrible things happen, you
know, but it doesn't work.
You know, we know it doesn't work.
And so I decided to follow
the model of science-based sex
education with no, abstinence
pledges don't work.
And so what I've been doing
in talking to high school
students,
generally I start with the
parents is just sort of say,
you know, experimentation happens.
I don't think parents should
necessarily be helping that
with, you know, parties or
whatever at their houses.
But we have to have talk
to kids about safety.
We have to talk to them about
what accidents look like.
We have to talk about what
an overdose looks like.
'cause actually teenagers right
now are the fastest growing
population of overdose victims
when it comes to opioids and
half of all assaults
involved drugs as well.
So when I go into schools,
I completely stick with the science,
you know what my conversations
with drugs with my own kids
and our own values are
different than the science
with my own kids, I do
use the science as well,
but I find it actually
incredibly refreshing.
Like teenagers, listen, I
go in, I show PET scans,
I show data, I show data, I show data.
I'm like, how do you help a friend?
How do you know what an overdose
looks like and when do you
get help and when does somebody
need naloxone and when do
you call 911?
I talk about what problematic
drug use looks like,
especially in the setting
of self-medication.
Talking about like kids
with depression, anxiety,
ADHD are much more
likely to be using drugs.
It's a little better faster
and it's easier to get your
hands on edible than it's
to get psychiatric care.
Right, so
- yeah, unfortunately.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And so talk about like
what problematic drug use
looks like and I think we
have to have these very frank
conversations with teenagers
if we're going to do anything
about honestly, future addiction.
'cause most drug problems do
begin in the teenage years
and it was kind of terrifying at first
to be honest with you.
Not just because I wasn't
telling people, you know,
don't do drugs,
but because I was really talking
about the science and I had
to learn how to phrase it in
a way that wasn't off putting.
- Yeah.
- And it wasn't annoying.
And frankly I found that teenagers
like it a lot more when I
talk now I talk to to parents, I sort of,
I focus on the like, you know, the,
the doom and gloom and
the risks, you know,
we're all gonna die, right?
And when I talk to teenagers,
I don't do that at all.
I really just stick
with the data and it's,
it's refreshing to have
it be very well received.
- Hmm.
- So I have hope for
this younger generation.
I have to say, you know,
I think it's a time when
before we have these ideas of,
you know, before we have our,
our fixed ideas and we want
the science to support what we
believe in, in some ways, you know,
teenagers just seem to be much
more open to information and
data is, you know,
they're still in school all
the time and they know a lot,
you know, they get on their
phones and they look stuff up.
So I don't dare say anything
that isn't backed up by data
because I know they'll
call me out in a minute.
- I'm curious, do you do ever do Q&A?
Because like you said,
- Oh yeah,
- Teens get a lot of information.
So at least in my experience,
there's often times where people
just wanna ask a scientist
a question, like, I saw
this, is this legit?
Is it not?
Or I think it's legit or are
you gonna convince me other,
I'm just curious what,
like what does that actually
look like when you do Q&A?
- I've been, you know,
I've been experimenting
with a format a fair amount,
it's easier with parents,
you know, it's easier,
you know, but with high school students,
at first I was talking to
schools and I got a very limited
amount of time and it just doesn't work.
You have to have the Q&A.
- Yeah.
- So now what I've been doing
is asking for a lot more time
and the best luck I've had is
actually with the school right
around the corner from here.
It's on 158 in Amsterdam where
the students set up a mental
health club and I spoke,
I was there for two hours
answering questions.
- Yeah.
- And it was one of the best
times I've ever had in my job.
- Wow.
Wow, that's great.
- They had fantastic questions
- Yeah, I mean it seems like,
I mean that's just obviously
just a sample of one,
but it seems like an ideal way to go.
It's really just open things
up and the fact that they have
that mental health club already.
I mean hearing from my own teen,
my own teenagers about the
lack of conversations around
these things sometimes, I mean
surprisingly it seems like,
and I could be wrong this,
but it seems like a lot of
teenagers actually want the
schools to talk about it more.
- Absolutely.
- At least in the
conversations I've had and the,
the schools that I've gone to and talked.
But sometimes I'm not sure why
this is but seems like maybe
there's a perception among our,
our age group that they don't
want it or we're talking about
too much, but that just not has been,
has not been my experience
talking to students
in the classroom.
- Absolutely.
They're very interested
in psychiatric disorders.
We talk about the symptoms,
we talk about treatments
and I talk a lot about the
interaction between having, you know,
mental health issues and drug
use and what that looks like.
- Yeah.
Well definitely appreciate the
work you're doing and again,
I mean I'm just hearing so
many themes between but what
you're both sharing from different
perspectives and starting
points, but with a lot
of commonalities as well.
Steven, is there anything you
wanted to kind of jump in on?
- Yeah,
I mean what you were just saying
really resonates with me as
well in the outreach I've done to,
to various aged people.
Probably not nearly as well
as you but you know, try.
And I will say also from my
personal experience when I was
coming up and starting to
learn for the first time
about drugs,
it was in the context of the
eighties kind of war on drugs
with just say no and
DARE and stuff like that.
And I actually think in that
case there was some aspects of
that quote education that
were ended up being harmful in
some way could end up being
harmful in the sense that there
were some things that were not
quite true and were a little
bit more along the lines of
kind of propaganda basically.
And you know, I found
myself saying, you know,
reading about, for example,
cannabis and hearing about how
it's going to do all kinds of
terrible things and you should
absolutely stay away from it.
And then, you know,
seeing my friends and also
experimenting myself with it at
the time and not dying and
not going crazy and so on,
and so I,
I guess I then wondered what
else was true and not true
about these drugs, you know?
- Yeah.
- So I think that
a little bit of, I think honesty
is key 'cause as you said,
kids are smart,
they have phones,
they can look things up and
see if you're lying to them or
not, and people don't like
being told what to do,
I don't think, and yeah,
but having the information
to make good choices,
that's the key aspect of this.
- I think that's exactly the point.
That's what I say, like
I'm providing you with the
information you should have to
make your best choices for yourself.
And the other thing that resonates
a lot with teenagers is I
talk about watching out for your friends.
- Hmm.
- Right, I talk about how,
you know, anyone who's
consciousness is in any way changed
by a drug, whether it's cannabis, alcohol,
and they're not really all
completely awake or completely
alert is at risk for being
the victim of an assault.
And we have a responsibility
to help our friends and they're
also at a risk of it being in an accident,
not even just car accidents
but riding a bike,
walking in the freezing cold.
I talk about how like almost
everyone has gone to a party
and had too much and people
get embarrassed and scared and
they try and solve the problem
on their own and that's
probably when they're the
biggest risk of danger and
why we should help each other.
And that actually resonates
with teenagers very well is
keeping an eye out for, you
know, their friends and their,
their fellow peers.
- Yeah, that's really good.
I mean,
I'm even imagining people who
are listening who are just
gonna take some of the advice,
not that you're giving
advice in that sense,
but some of the things that
you've learned and actually
apply that as well.
And I do appreciate how
you put that in context.
'Cause you said at the beginning
that you were experimenting
you weren't exactly sure how
it would go, you were nervous.
So it seems like you gave
yourself space to learn that as
well, which I think is key.
And actually just ties into, you know,
what we heard about from Steve
and Steve and your bio as well,
just having that learning process
and really taking the time
to see what's effective and
what resonates with people.
So I think that's huge.
- Yep, it took a while
with the teenagers, but I,
I kind of finally got,
I practiced on my own kids for a while.
They're like, mom,
we're sick of hearing it.
I'm like too bad.
- That's the best,
that's the most critical and
most helpful audience though if
they're willing to go there
with you 'cause they'll tell you
straight up whether it's resonate or not.
And I can,
I mean I can tell also that
you have a lot of authenticity
about it as well.
Just being realistic about the situation.
I know that definitely will
resonate with the groups that
you're speaking to.
- And we have a lot more data
than, you know, you know,
experimenting with drug
use in the eighties.
I understand that completely.
But you know,
it's now 2020s and we have,
you know, 40 years of data,
so we really now go in with data.
- Yeah.
- And we, you know, we have all of this,
we have all this incredible
just treasure chest of
information and an
audience wants to hear it.
- Yeah, definitely agree.
Well, in a lot of ways, you
know, you all are preaching,
I'm preaching to the choir
in a sense because it,
this is what you are all both
passionate about and clearly
you've taken initiative
and having good science
communication.
But if you remove yourself
from the equation for a moment
and just think about
society at large, let's go,
let's go a little bit smaller.
Let's just think about the scientific
and medical enterprise.
That's probably not the
right word to use but
I'll use it anyway.
How well do you think we actually
communicate about science
to the general public and those around us?
Not you all as individuals,
but just more globally?
Steve, look, you look like
you're ready to jump in.
- Yeah,
I think we need to do way
better is the long story short.
You know,
part of the issue here is that
it is one of the realities
that people may or may not be familiar
with regard to science in the,
at least in the United
States is that, you know,
so for example we study addiction
and we are funded largely
by the National Institutes
of Health, which,
and specifically by the National
Institute on Drug Abuse.
Which is ultimately means
that the research we're doing
should have a specific
application to health in humans to
help treat people with
addiction for example,
or to identify risk factors
for addiction and so on.
And I think a lot of our
research does try to do that.
But I think there's also a lot
of research that is funded by
the National Institutes of
Health that may sort of be
described as being coming, you know,
perhaps we'll come up with
the next cure or the next
breakthrough.
But in fact it's really basic
science and I think that's
okay, like I think that ultimately
with the brain is such a
mystery and,
and the how psychiatric
disorders work and why one person
has one and one doesn't with
seemingly similar genetic
predispositions and environmental
experiences and things.
It's a very mysterious and I think it is,
it's just the fact that we need
to understand how the brain
works better in the first
place and not everything we're
going to do is gonna have health
impacts in the short term.
And I think there's some
tension there because
ultimately the National
Institutes of Health is funded by
the federal government and
for health purposes, and so,
and it's sort of an uncomfortable
fact that when we tell
politicians that we're doing
basic science that's probably
not gonna have short-term
benefits to Americans,
that is, maybe we get cut,
the budgets get cut faster
and things like that.
And so there's this little like sort of,
I don't quite wanna call it a fiction,
but I think a little bit of a,
a failure on our part to
be open about this reality.
And I think the downside of it is,
is something that probably most
of us have experienced when
you see on the news that the
new breakthrough for whatever
is out there and you know it's
gonna change everything and
then it doesn't, or you
know, this whatever it is,
eggs are good for you,
eggs are bad for you,
that kind of stuff.
It just makes it seem like
science is just, you know,
up for grabs.
Like anyone could have their own opinion.
It's just as good as a scientific finding
and that's not the case.
And I think we need to do
better about communicating the
fact that science isn't imperfect,
is a process being wrong.
Making a a guess that is wrong
and is proven wrong is called
progress.
And that's not failure,
it's actually how we make progress.
These are the kinds of things
I think we scientists need to
be a little bit more,
a little bit better at
conveying to the general public.
- Yeah, really well said.
A follow-up question,
'cause you've given
some concrete examples,
do you have thoughts either
of you on how we actually do
that as scientists?
Like what might be some
effective practice?
And I realize I'm getting into
kind of behavioral science
and you know, organizational psychology,
not even organizational but
just community psychology and
those types of things.
But curious if you all
had any thoughts on that.
- Addy hour?
I'm serious though in that
this is the kind of, you know,
cross-cutting conversations
that I think really can resonate
with different audiences.
Maybe someone finds your podcast through,
through a faith-based avenue.
Maybe some are neuroscientists,
some are coming from,
you know,
there's a lot of different
places that you end up watching
this pod or listening to this podcast.
And that then exposes people
that are not necessarily or
sort of think neurosciences
too complicated or something
with, you know,
the kind of conversations
that you're having here.
I think it can potentially make a,
a difference in the world.
- I definitely appreciate
that and to share a story.
I mean I have seen that as
well 'cause as, you know,
as I've done kind of the,
the standard academic thing of
talking to different schools,
I've had faculty members
who've told me, oh I have,
you know,
I have a sister who's not a
scientist who told me about your
podcast, so it does seem like
in those ways it is at least
penetrating into different
audiences and people are picking
it up and having
conversations that they might
not have otherwise.
So that's definitely encouraging
and even though I laughed,
I didn't expect you to say that,
but still definitely encouraging.
Diana what about you for
answering just a question of how,
and then maybe going back after
that to the question of if
we do a good job at all.
- And I actually, I think
they fit together because,
you know, I like the example
of eggs are good, eggs are bad.
You know, that's part of the
problem is that, you know,
when it comes to,
when it comes to just sort of
like boiling science down into
little bitty sound bites,
it doesn't work right?
Because it's complicated, right?
Eggs are so good for some
people, bad for other people.
I always, you know, I do also give some,
I do some CME courses on
medicinal cannabis to other
physicians and you know, does
cannabis cure everything?
No, is it completely harmless?
No, and so it was complicated.
So you know, for example,
cannabis is good for,
or it can help with pain,
anxiety and insomnia.
That's great if you're treating
a patient with multiple
sclerosis or with cancer pain,
but not if you're treating
an 18 year old with ADHD.
So you know, it's you, the problem is,
is we know a lot more,
but it's complicated and it's
very hard to just sort of
parse it down into one
little tiny, you know,
three line article or one
little tiny, you know, bit on a,
on a news channel.
And so it really does require
forums in which you can have
longer conversations and
sort of explain the nuances.
So we do need to have more
sort of patience on the part of
society at large with science
because it's not so simple
anymore.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's really well said.
I mean that thing that you were
mentioning too is just being
able to slow down.
I guess the conundrum is how
do you slow down in a society
that is only speeding up?
- Yeah.
- And I mean, you know, in some
ways I would say, you know,
I'm guilty of kind of trying
to at least use that to an
advantage as well.
I mean you all may know
we actually have some,
like we launched a TikTok channel too,
which is more sound bite,
but trying to at least craft
a way to at least pull in
enough to give something that sounds,
but not maybe full because you
can't always get into nuances
and knowing how to do that.
I mean, I think in some ways too,
what I've heard from
others is just, and Diana,
this gets to your work too,
but the utility of actually
starting in schools too,
where you can actually incorporate
this into kids' language
early on.
So one example,
I had an opportunity to speak
to all the superintendents and
boards of education in the state
of Connecticut a few months
back and to hear some of the
teachers who were there also
talk about the ways they're
incorporating some of the
language in elementary school
and having the kids think
about the prefrontal cortex
and regulating emotions.
So like at,
at that point there's more
time to kind of really nurture
that understanding.
Not to say that we should
give up on adults, but it's a,
it's a very different type of
conversation in terms of speed
of conversation, attention span,
willingness to listen and
all the other things that as
adults we've learned to,
what's the best way to put it?
Conditioning is one aspect
of it, but just having,
I'm using all these words
incorrectly, it's not hardwired,
but I feel like we act
as if it's hardwired.
We have so many thoughts that we're like,
this is the way the world is.
I mean we do that as scientists,
we do that in society and to
really have time to kind of
break that up and start all
over again I think is important.
But in some ways easier to
do with younger folks who are
more open to actually
hearing those things,
especially when you come
with that authenticity that
Diana mentioned.
So I feel like that was a
little bit of a tangent, but.
- The other thing I
think that we can do is
as a neuroscientist or scientist is to,
is to kind of try to open up the field
to more kinds of people.
To diverse perspectives.
- Yeah.
- To diverse populations of
people so that we can, you know,
you know,
I mean I guess like the way
science is often perceived as
like, you know,
you have some egghead in a lab
coat or something and they're
just, you know,
not something that I do
that's not a person like me.
And I think when you start to you know,
have people interact
with these, with kids of,
of coming from different
backgrounds and things and who then
can bring in their own
perspectives and ideas,
new ideas.
This is another path
forward I think is to,
is to really try something
a little different.
You know,
I would argue that our
neuroscience that we've had so far
has not been very successful
at helping people or not as
much as it could.
And I think this might be part
of the problem is we are a
little bit too heavily focused
on the exact thing that,
you know, we've always
studied and I think we,
we need new ideas.
- Yeah, really well said.
And Diana
I don't know if I'm putting
you on the spot here,
but as Steve mentioned,
that makes me think of the
philosophy talk that you gave at
an addiction conference to
neuroscientist and how much of a
shift that was, and that's,
I mean that's why Steve and I
had such a long conversation
afterwards because forcing
us to think about things in a
different way that we
don't always think about.
Although I feel like some of it was there,
but when most of us just don't
articulate it or take the
time to actually delve into that.
So I'm curious if you, you know,
on the spot we wanted to share
at least some of the things
that you've been thinking
about around those realms.
So just this one example of
integrating from different
perspectives.
- Yeah, so when I was asked
to give that talk, because I,
my undergraduate degree was
in philosophy and when I was
asked to give the talk, my
first reaction was like, yeah,
sure, why not?
And then I thought about it,
I'm like, what am I gonna say?
And honestly, like I spent probably,
I spent many months working on that talk
it was really like really you
thought long and hard about
it, 'cause like I, like, I
dunno what I'm gonna say.
And it actually had a real
change in my career thinking
about that talk because what
I really tried to think about
in that talk was what do we
mean when we think of bad?
What do we mean when we think
of bad behavior and we think
of, you know, injury to
self or injury to others.
And so I try to take examples
of psychiatric disorders that
involve harm to others.
- Hmm.
- And the top of that list is, you know,
antisocial personality
disorder and pedophilia.
And I ask myself, you know,
are these brain disorders?
And did a lot of research on them,
have started a new project
looking at antisocial personality
disorder and view it as being
antisocial and a personality
disorder, but really if you
break it down into its pieces,
it comes down to impulse
control, impulsivity.
And I think there's a lot
of data to suggest that it,
that there's difficulty
understanding social situations.
And most people have anti-social
personality disorder,
they don't understand the
situation well and when it doesn't
go in the way that they expect
it to, the reaction is anger.
And we all have situations
in which we have social
interaction that doesn't
go the way we expect it to.
And sometimes we react
with sadness or shame or
embarrassment or anger.
And when we react with anger,
it's because we think we're right.
So when you and I have a social
interaction that doesn't go
well and we react with
something other than anger,
we think that, oh, maybe
we're wrong, right?
So somebody who reacts with
anger tends to not understand
what happened.
And so I've been trying to do
more research on anti-social
personality disorder
looking at impulsivity
and social cognition.
So I'm trying to start that up.
And then I also,
in that talk I talked about
pedophilia, which was,
that was tough, you know,
like I asked myself the question is
pedophilia a brain disorder?
And I think I mentioned like
my first reaction was like,
Lord, I don't know and I don't wanna know.
My second reaction was I really
don't want the FBI banging
down my door.
But you know, I've been looking up and,
and reading more about it.
It's deeply understudied
and honestly, you know, we,
we shy away from it but it is
a brain disorder and honestly
what would be the worst that happens
if we were to find a treatment?
There may be fewer future victims
and yet we still can't get
our head around it, it's
completely understudied.
It's underfunded.
There hasn't been a
grant funded since 2008.
What's interesting to me about pedophilia,
and this is a study I
wanna do down the road,
although hopefully no one's
listening for my institution
'cause I think I'll have a
freak out if I do this study.
But there is some hint to
suggest that there's a lot of
overlap between obsessive
thinking and pedophilia.
And I wonder if we could
look at it more from the
perspective of OCD especially at least in,
in patients who want treatment,
which is the place to start.
So even though I mostly do
neuroscience and addiction and
certainly, you know,
antisocial personality disorder
has a lot of overlap with
addiction and I think pedophilia does too.
I think there's a lot of substance
use we don't really know.
I'm starting to move and,
and look and see if we can get
beyond just thinking of these
as being fixed bad brains
into thinking like,
can we break it down into the
symptoms because we know how
to treat some of these symptoms.
- Yeah, that's really, really
well said and I appreciate,
I mean there's so many pieces
that you brought up too,
just even in terms of, you
know, flying out for what,
what Steven was mentioning
about the ways that we
communicate, but then
even a layer beneath that,
what do we actually think
about and investigate and study
and what do we shy away from
and all the reasons, Steve,
if you look like you might
have a comment to jump in with.
- Yeah, I mean it's just
fascinating and obviously like,
you know,
pedophilia I think is not
something we do talk about very
much as a scientific field.
And I think the reason is because
the first thing that comes
to mind is, you know,
disgust or you know these,
maybe people are evil or
there's something like really,
you know, bad about them and so on.
And that's the case in a very real way.
And I would say that that is
to some extent also the case
with addiction, many times we,
even though we know that there
is ultimately in some way
addiction is a brain disorder as well,
it does cause people to do
terrible things to other people
and to themselves certainly.
And I think that's also a little
bit an aspect of a lot of a
psychiatric disorder.
Something wrong with you
that's like a bad thing.
There's something bad about you.
And I don't think we really
have that impression of other
types of brain disorders
like Alzheimer's disease for
example, or Parkinson's disease.
I don't think anyone really
is frequently blaming those
people and thinking they're,
they're bad because their brain
is broken and it's causing
them to have, you know, lots of problems.
And I'd argue that's because
we understand those disorders a
little bit better.
We have something that is
biological that it like actually
causes it, whereas in,
for example, addiction,
people are just making bad
choices and that is the disorder
in some ways, and that's, you know,
hard to get your head around
how this thing could be,
you know, how a person can, you know,
kind of have free will and yet
still be controlled by their,
you know, brain in some way.
And I don't know,
it's just these are really
tough topics to wrestle with and
obviously especially for,
for something as sensitive as pedophilia.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean definitely like,
even as I'm listening to both of you talk,
this kind of ties everything
back together 'cause it speaks
to both how much more we
need to be talking about
and thinking about and
investigating these things.
So if we're not even doing that,
how can we actually communicate
it to the public if we can't
even have those conversations ourselves?
So, you know, Diana here,
what you're already wrestling
through and trying to think
about that type of work,
I think is so important.
And it gets back to, I mean,
the work that we have to do
internally in a sense and also
externally, not that any
of us can do it on our own,
but something that we kind of
have to do in collaboration
with one another, so, I
mean, I think this is,
it's helpful because it's a
good, it's a challenge point.
It speaks to the hope
that can come from that,
but also the reality of the
fact that there's still work to
be done in a lot of ways.
- And certainly, you know,
when it comes to antisocial
personality disorder and which I
mean, you know,
most of my participants here
in my studies will most all
have substance use disorders
and a fair number really do
have either anti-social
personality disorder or in that
sort of range of things.
And I don't mean people
who completely lack,
we often think of anti-social
personality disorders,
completely lacking empathy.
That's not actually really the case.
It was a really nice study
done recently that interviewed
3000 people with anti-social
personality disorder and only
20% reported symptoms
like lack of empathy,
cruelty to animals and bullying.
Most of the symptoms are
things like, you know,
not paying rent, not following through,
quitting a job without a job
to follow up with, you know,
stealing, you know,
certainly behaviors that are,
are problematic but aren't
necessarily sort of like a,
you know, a monster like
lack of empathy or sympathy.
And so I do think we have an
obligation for this patient
population because studies
show that 40% of patients with
opioid use disorder have ASPD.
And if we can treat this part of it,
then 40% of people may not
respond to our treatments.
- Yeah.
- To bring it back to rodents,
I think one thing that we do
need to be looking at, and I,
and something that I think is
happening in the rodent field,
y'all have to tell me
more, is sort of, you know,
looking at the role of,
of social stress and social
status and social and how that
fits, and when it comes to
substance use disorders,
comorbidity is a huge issue.
Anxiety, depression, ASPD, ADHD,
but all those comorbidities have in common
impaired social function.
So I think that's one
thing that runs across
psychiatric disorders.
- Yeah.
It could be modeled in animal studies and
and really help us.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and we frequently,
I will say as the,
as an animal researcher, we
frequently don't do that.
And I think that's really, I,
I couldn't agree with you more
that this is a huge aspect of
human life of all these disorders
you're talking about and
also of rat's lives.
And I don't know if they
have disorders or not,
but they certainly suffer
from social isolation,
for example, they care what
other rats think of them,
that kind of thing.
And you know,
how could it be the case that
that's irrelevant for the kind
of neuroscience studies we're
doing, it seems impossible,
but I argue that the real reason,
the main reason why we
don't study these, we,
I mean I think there's a lot
of neuroscience would agree
with that statement, but
we still don't study it.
So why, maybe one of the
reasons is simply that it's,
it's hard, it's more inconvenient
to add those variables
into your studies.
There's not a lot of interest
from funding sources to do
these, again,
basic science kinds of questions
to try to understand these
more difficult but probably
extremely important factors.
So yeah, I think there's
a growing, as you said,
a growing group of people that
are starting to realize that
we are simply missing a huge
part of the puzzle here.
If we're studying rats in
solitary confinement and seeing
how much they take drugs, which
they don't know are illegal,
they're not illegal for them, they're not,
they don't know anything
about the health consequences.
Why wouldn't a rat take drugs in my lab?
You know, there's ways we can get at that.
We can say, you know,
you must choose between hanging
out with a buddy and taking
some drug, for example.
- Yeah.
- Now we're in the ballpark
of the kind of choices people
are really making when they're addicted.
- Yeah, yeah.
Really well said.
Well this has been a great
conversation in true form I think
we've covered a lot of ground
in terms of the work that
you're both doing in research,
but then also in commuting and society.
And I think you also have
nicely given a lot of challenges
to folks as well.
So I'll say by way of
story, it has been nice,
and this goes back to Steve's
comment about the Addy Hour,
but it's been nice to see the
ways that people have actually
been using the podcast,
whether that be like a loose
journal club type of thing
where, you know,
institutes are watching it
and having a conversation in
small groups afterwards,
or universities have reached
out and actually want to use
episodes for courses and things like that.
So I mentioned that because I
think a lot of what you both
have talked about would be
really helpful for people to
actually incorporate into a
classroom setting or into a
journal club setting or a
research discussion to really
think about where are the points
that we really need to kind
of push things forward both
within our research endeavors,
but in society in a larger way as well.
So obviously you both are here
so you can disseminate the,
the podcast to those in
your spheres of influence.
But I mean,
there's ways I think that we
could actually even do that
more because,
just because of all the important
topics that you both have
brought up,
which I think are really relevant
and important for us on a
much broader scale.
So I definitely appreciate
the ways that you both
have done that.
Any closing words that you wanna leave
with audience members?
I'm gonna leave it wide open
cuz there's lots of stuff that
we've talked about and
directions you could take things.
But Diana, you wanna start?
- Yeah.
So you mentioned that you were doing some,
some TikTok videos and honestly
I think TikTok is a great
way to go, like I think
TikTok can handle, you know,
what I was talking about,
like sort of like complex,
you know,
that science is complicated
and little bits at a time.
Like, you know, some TikTok
videos have misinformation,
but there are also some that
just sort of like in a short
period of time can explain like, you know,
the importance of, I don't know,
like you how allergies work or dental
- Yeah.
- Mental health.
And so, you know, it can, you can break,
you can break complicated
scientific conversations down
into bits that can fit into short formats.
I think, I mean it's a
challenge, but I think it's,
it's doable.
- Yeah.
I'm glad you feel that way.
That helps as we're continuing
to endeavor to do that.
So that's great advice.
- Yeah, I guess, you know,
not everyone can be great at everything.
So a lot of scientists are
fantastic at their research,
are fantastic at, you know,
lots of aspects of their life,
writing papers, grants, et cetera.
But maybe they're really bad
science communicators and
that's okay, you know, not
everyone has to do everything.
And that's why I think we need
to value a bunch of different
kinds of skills.
Not just the ones that are
how much money can you get on
grants and how many papers
and what impact and high,
high profile journals
and things like that.
That's stuff's fine and it's
important, but you know,
we need to have also people
that can actually do a TikTok
channel that kids will want to hear.
- Mm.
- That can actually communicate
and across disciplines,
across a kind of perspectives
like you are here
with this podcast.
You know, this is something that I,
I'm really very happy that
you are performing the service
and I'm, you know, as I
said before, honored to be,
you know, play a tiny role
of a 41st episode of it here.
We need to do more of this and,
and thank you Nii for leading the way.
- Of course.
Well as you know 'cause you
saw my newsletter this week,
I feel like this is a huge
collaboration just with folks
like you,
so many people who've come on
the podcast to really share
because I think that's also
something that resonates with
people to be able to hear
something about one topic from a
whole bunch of different perspectives.
And it goes back to both of
the things that you all have
mentioned, so it's been
an honor for me as well.
This has been a really,
really fun conversation.
And you know,
I'm saying that with sincerity
that I hope people really
amplify what you all
have talked about today.
'Cause there really is a
potential for this to really
kind of transform how people
are thinking about things on a
day-to-day basis and big picture as well.
So thanks to both of you for your support,
your willingness to jump on
and for everything that you
shared with the listeners today.
- Great, thank you.
It was great to be here.
- Of course.
(upbeat music)